Jon Bernthal has less than a minute in
the movie widows I'm gonna focus my
entire review on this fact god I love
this app oh that's right I'm shooting a
movie review what was I doing on my
phone tell ya I was hung to start us at
people you see over there John and I we
do 30 second reaction reviews for any
film TV show or trailer and sometimes we
do micro sketches I was just watching
some of our awesome videos on here you
know it's cool about this app it's free
to download it's free to use why'd you
tell Aviv and Paulo is to take awkward
transition to the actual review of this
movie alright so last night I saw the
new Steve McQueen flick widows and I've
really been looking forward to this film
by the way I'm wearing my Wonder Woman
shirt cuz it's the closest thing I have
to resembling a female cast but now it's
all covered in cat hair so I'm
camera-ready
so out of a two hour flick here's the
setup for this movie it's very simple
easy to follow leave me simply is Harry
Rawlings after him and his crew are
killed in a heist gone wrong his wife
Veronica Rawlings played by Viola Davis
who was insanely good why she's so good
and like what that what is she what are
you Viola who are you any of our
grieving Veronica Rawlings is forced to
pay a debt towards Jamal Manning played
by Bryan Tyree Henry I'm his biggest fan
I know exactly who that is he's the man
Liam Neeson and his team stole two
million dollars from that's about as
much money as Tyrone Magnus makes in a
week so Viola Davis recruits two of the
widows from her late husband's team
played by Michelle Rodriguez and
Elizabeth to Vicki to pull off the heist
and as you saw in the trailer Cynthia
Revo eventually joins the widows team
also they can pull off a heist to pay
off the debt owed to Jamal who has a
scary ass violent brother played by
Daniel Cole ooh yeah oh yeah Jamal is
also running for mayor against Colin
Farrell who has a famous politician
father played by Robert Duvall and then
there's other characters and stuff
that's a set up of the movie yeah it's a
lot it's a lot yet the film doesn't feel
overstuffed which is something I cannot
say for another movie that came out this
weekend so before I go into reviewing
this movie I just like to say that I
like this film in fact I
might have really liked it a lot and
leaving the theater there were elements
in there that I wasn't too sure how I
felt about them it's not to say I don't
like those elements I just was unsure
about if I liked or didn't like them
let's talk about the things I for sure
know are good about this film for
starters it's pretty obvious goes
without saying the cast is obviously
great in this movie and since there's a
lot of cast members in here I'm only
gonna focus on the ones that really left
an impact on me and that's the women
because women are awesome seriously
every female performer in this delivers
such a nuanced performance I didn't feel
like this is a film about strong women I
mean yeah they are strong women but the
movie wasn't like in my face about it
because the main women in this film are
widows who are all grieving in their own
unique ways there's a lot of pain behind
each of the widow's roles
Viola Davis is a lead and she brings all
the things we love about Viola Davis
she's in a lot of pain but she has to do
everything she can to remain focused and
stay strong despite the fact that she's
battling emotions of grief Elizabeth de
vikke is very much a battered woman and
instead of the movie shoving it in my
face
saying look she's a victim feel sorry
for her she'll be strong eventually the
writing and performance combined gave us
a character that's so easy to latch on
to you care for her because she's a
great character it was fascinating
seeing Michelle Rodriguez in this movie
you know she's in the Fast & Furious
franchise and the Resident Evil ones but
that is mad those Fast and Furious
franchises have a woman in there but
they're kind of just in the background
they're in Samba base their team base
and are usually pulling off ridiculous
missions and sometimes as her heist I
know she herself had a complaint about
how women are portrayed in those films
or not given much to do I don't remember
the exact complaint I'm sure I have some
quote here thrown in but in this film
she truly gets to demonstrate her acting
chops she's more than just tough Latina
chick for characters when left as a
single mother of two I don't know if
she's a mom in real life but I believe
her here she's hated by her
mother-in-law I'm not married but I'm
sure my mother-in-law in the future will
definitely hate me so I identified
instead of just one note tough brooding
Michelle Rodriguez she gives a very
3-dimensional performance
Cynthia Revo is not one of the widow's
but they
trailers new show she joins the team and
since she's barely in and I'll just say
this I thought she was fantastic in bad
times at the El Royale her performance
here is definitely really good but the
thing that I was most surprised by was
her physical capabilities and bad time
she's able to really demonstrate her
emotional capacity her singing abilities
and then here she has a lot of physical
work to do which made me go this woman
should be an action star there's one
shot in the movie where she's running
kind of like Tom Cruise meets the t1000
very impressive stuff Daniel Kahlua
I wasn't sure who he was gonna portray
in this movie all I'll say is the dude
is pretty scary
he's not exactly given insane amounts of
dialogue but I really appreciate the
subtlety of his performance because at
first view and you might be thinking
Daniel Kahlua is in this but his
characters not really fleshed out on
screen but it's Daniel Cole ooh yeah
come on but I don't think his character
fully needs to be and there's little
things here there that I really like
that show extra layers of depth added to
his character but there's one moment
where he's stalking someone and there's
audio on how to speak Spanish playing in
his car and I do that all the time when
I'm stalking people there's another
moment before he's doing something
important where he just walks in and
he's apparently been like halfway
through a book we don't know what book
it is we don't know why he's reading it
but it just shows that he's more than
just tough guy who does tough things for
his brother who's more important than
him I thought they were good visual cues
to give us insight into his character
without being expositional about
anything
Collin Farrel is a politician who's
stuck being in his father's shadow and
he's an antagonist of sorts I think all
Farrell did a pretty good job in this
movie he's not exactly one of the shiney
performances of the film but he does a
good job he's effective Robert Duvall
he's one of the things I'm a little bit
unsure about there were times where I
couldn't tell if he was doing a really
good job as a rage-fueled
old man and having some weird choices
with his delivery or is he just too old
to be on camera
so there's times I just couldn't fully
get into what he was doing cuz I was
questionable about is this intentional
or she's just really old now the unique
kind of direction I find that Steve
McQueen often provides is that he often
tells stories in a variation of two
specific ways one is a like a dark slice
of life and then the other direct
you can tend to go down is very poetic
storytelling because the trailers might
have you go in thinking that this is
gonna be like one intense thrill ride
it's gonna escalating Lee get crazier
when really it doesn't feel that way
there's a lot of characters in here that
you follow if anything it ultimately
feels like the most realistic heist
movie you will ever see even thinking
about the actual heist itself it's not
exactly that crazy compared to you know
what we usually see in movies but the
emotional stakes and build-up to it are
very much felt which intensifies it so
what it all goes down it is it is pretty
pretty freakin gripping yeah it's pretty
cool but majority of this film is really
a drama where you're studying these
people's lives the way they feel about
others the way they feel about
themselves a lot of grieving a lot of
corruption and then themes that touch on
racism while this plot is slowly moving
towards the eventual heist it was cool
to watch because there were moments
where I was a little bit unsure about
the actual direction of where Steve
McQueen chose to point the camera so why
certain things ago that's weird
why did that and then when I think about
it I go oh you know it might actually be
that happen quite often there were
things where I would go why did that
happen or why did they choose to do it
this way then when I would really think
about it I would come to a certain
conclusion I don't know if I'm right
about that but I often liked the
conclusions I jump to but then there are
other moments that are just kind of
weird there's surprisingly a lot of
weirder interesting choices that were
taken that I did not expect it be a
spoiler if I if I really went into it
I've missed a couple people have really
reference to a specific moment with
Michelle Rodriguez and I know exactly
what they're talking about because if
you watch the movie or if you have seen
the movie you know exactly what moment
I'm referring to
it's a moment with her character where I
could feel the intent of you know the
unspoken words and the body language and
everything that it's about and not
really what's being said the more poetic
romanticizing side of Steve McQueen and
not so much the realistic slice of life
nuance he tends to have if you've seen
the film you'll know exactly what I'm
referring to but even acknowledging the
intent of that moment I also may feel
like it's certain moments like that
where it's sort of sprinkled throughout
where it makes certain
voices about the film's direction a
little questionable I quite enjoyed all
the stuff that just felt very realistic
I felt like real life but in terms of
some of its more poetic elements it can
sometimes feel like certain plot lines
don't fully pay off occasionally it can
start to feel like well what happened
with these characters and their
storylines but there are others where I
question it and I found myself able to
fill in the blanks based off previous
scenes or at least be satisfied with my
own interpretation because so deep amaze
me how deep I hashtag Dean I know it
might be kind of confusing what I'm
saying I guess what I'm saying is that
some moments are really left open to
interpretation and someone was really
left for you to fill in the blank spaces
sometimes when that happens there you're
like I wish I had some explanations on
that but then there are other moments
where I go you know I don't think we
needed an explanation on that and I like
it and with you know heist John remove
ease like this even if Steve McQueen's
directing it I guess they're gonna throw
in moments that have certain twists
there's a particularly big one that
wouldn't happen I was like and I think
the whole crowd was like whoa that's an
early twist but as the film progressed I
was kind of wishing this twist wasn't in
the movie I kind of thought it took away
some of the emotional strength of its
specific tale so ultimately didn't feel
all that necessary I didn't really think
it was utilized
either way it's a heist movie that has a
lot of artistic choices throughout it
has sprinkles of messages here there
that often deal with racism is something
I didn't expect
there was another element to this movie
where I would go is this really
necessary for this movie then again it
goes so in tune with the characters in
the world they live in and because it's
ultimately a dark character study
and when I say study it does feel like
that it's sort of an observational piece
of these people at this moment in time
while there were enough moments of
intensity I was never quite emotionally
moved by the drama as often as I would
like to have been but even when I wasn't
I was always fascinated and I was also
very interested the entire time I was
watching it weirdly I feel like on a
second viewing I might be more
emotionally moved by everything since
there's a lot to take in throughout
there's a lot of plot unfolding
throughout and there's a lot of
character study going on throughout so
I'm actually very curious to know what
audiences think about this I know
critics are really liking it
but I wonder what the CinemaScore is
gonna be because at the time of shooting
this I don't know either way I do really
recommend this movie I quite enjoyed it
I don't know who's gonna like it and I
don't know who's gonna love it I don't
really know anyone was gonna hate this
movie except for Kristian harloff who
apparently didn't like it loved the idea
of the movie hated the execution I hate
it I like and I recommend it do you guys
see widows what's your favorite Steve
McQueen movie that could either be the
director the famous legendary actor or
that pretty guy from The Vampire Diaries
and piranha 3d Carmen go up you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell hey check us out
in the Stardust app free to download
free to use I like free stuff do you
you